[Music]
what's up everybody we're pongfinity
we're super excited to announce that we
have just launched our first bonfire
table thinnest product
in today's video we're going to show you
this net which can turn almost anything
into a tableton's table and we also have
our very own professional level
pongfinity ball
you can buy these from pongfinity.store
and during the first 24 hours we've got
a special campaign for you guys
where every single order gets a greeting
card signed by all three of us
we're gonna play a match using this net
where every point will be on a different
table
let's go the cabinets
[Music]
okay next up chopping board this looks
pretty difficult
[Laughter]
straight in the eye
treasure chest
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
no why did i have to go for the hard one
no i've got this i've got this
it's my point this is intense
[Music]
okay next is the oven tray
[Music]
it was good sounding okay this table is
a bit bigger
[Music]
[Music]
it went into the sink next up the pot
lid
[Music]
i like this it's making it quite easy
[Music]
who won the point how did i manage to
lose that
you are in control of the game i've got
the tray i can do anything
okay car roof this is something i
haven't tried before
i have to see the slow motion
[Music]
the seagull is cheering for me or me
i took the sides
[Music]
a window
[Music]
lucky point
can you handle the swaying easily
i'm gonna go fishing
okay good game we had so much fun
filming this you guys have to get your
own from pongfinity.store
we've been working really hard to make
this happen so hopefully you guys
enjoy our product making an order will
also be a big support to our channel
so head over to pongfinity.store until
next time